ahora bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad nos acompaña el
reconocidísimo escritor y periodista
martín caparrós el licenciado en
historia en parís france se haya
publicado más de 30 libros a lo largo de
30 países el último es ni américa cuyo
ejemplar lo tengo aquí en mis manos en
sus páginas recordar regiones de américa
latina y lo hace para intentar responder
a la pregunta qué y cómo es lo que él
llama y ya sabremos por qué ni américa
en su búsqueda hace estallar mitos
también los lugares comunes y muchos
imaginarios heredados si queremos
entender un poco más a nuestra región es
un libro ideal martín caparrós
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24 al contrario gracias a ustedes
bueno martín comencemos por el título no
hay una etnia que llama la atención
porque ni américa bueno porque el libro
en realidad trata como decías de
entender que es ahora américa latina'
pero en realidad esto que acabo de decir
es mentira porque no trata sobre el
conjunto de américa latina porque en
algún momento del trabajo decidí
y concentrarme en los 20 países que
hablan castellano dejar afuera brasil
que me parecía que
complicaba y de forma va un poco todo el
relato porque es un lugar que tiene su
propia historia sus propias tradiciones
y sus propias dimensiones particulares y
además es tan grande que falsea todos
los datos eso es una complicación y me
pareció que en cambio el hecho de que
haya 20 países que hablan un mismo
idioma es inédito es único en el mundo y
que valía la pena trabajar esa franja
digamos pero claro eso no es américa
latina porque américa latina incluye a
brasil entonces necesitaba un nombre
nuevo está el nombre más viejísimo
hispanoamérica si yo digo hispano
américa nadie lo dice gratis sólo 17
pagan por decirles es locutor de algún
acto oficial y te pagan por decirlo
entonces estaba sin nombre estaba sin
nombre para la región de la cual quería
ocuparme y en algún momento se me
ocurrió esto bueno si lo que de alguna
forma representa un ala a esos 20 países
es que hablamos castellano y si el
estandarte del castellano finalmente es
la seña bueno por qué no jugar con
américa y la ñ y de ahí salió américa
que va a ser todo no se puede
exactamente son los 20 países que
hablamos castellano te propongo martín
seguir con un recorrido no por conceptos
e ideas muy interesantes que planteas en
tu libro hay algo muy interesante que
tiene que ver también hay cierta pelea
ahí con el progresismo no hubo marcas
que hay una tendencia que proviene del
progresismo a un cuestionamiento mejor
dicho que tiende a clamar lo que es la
pureza no lo que es la tradición lo puro
entre comillas digamos como si lo
auténtico estuviese en lo originario no
ya y realmente es un planteo muy
interesante que decís que ahora cuando
decimos pueblos originarios tiene que
ver con cierta culpa no hablas de cierta
forma de bajo de baja de paternalismo a
qué atribuyes esta tendencia y sobre
todo quisiera preguntarte qué
consecuencias tiene esta tendencia que
daba bueno a mí efectivamente me parece
muy curioso que los sectores que se
dicen progresistas y que en muchos
aspectos lo son
hagan tanto esfuerzo porque algunos
otros sectores tengan que seguir
viviendo atados a sus tradiciones este
hecho es lógico pensar que
todos deberíamos progresar o en fin
cambiar al mismo ritmo y que no por
formar parte de grupos sociales que
hayan sido maltratados reprimidos como
en general pasó con los indios en
américa latina'
habría que reivindicar para ellos que
vivió al igual que su tatarabuelo a
nosotros no queremos vivir igual que
nuestras tatarabuelas más bien todo lo
contrario hacemos grandes esfuerzos por
mejorar lo que nosotros creemos que es
mejorar nuestras vidas cambiando las
tradiciones y las costumbres porque para
esos grupos reivindicamos el hecho de
que no las cambien hay una contradicción
rara que yo creo que efectivamente tiene
que ver con alguna forma de paternalismo
de culpa también porque nosotros
finalmente en muchos casos somos parte
de aquellos que los maltrataron
pero pero que a mí me preocupa no sólo
por esta confusión sino porque
yo no creo que el por el origen alguien
tenga que ser distinto en este sentido
está muy claro hay muchos pobres en
américa latina y es decisivo que mejoren
su condición pero yo no creo que un
pobre de origen indio puro tenga que
mejorar más su condición que un pobre de
origen absolutamente mezclado y además
cualquier idea de esta de pureza de
pureza de sangre de pureza de raza a mí
me produce cierto escalofrío de
genocidios en nombre de esa mujer esa
pureza y hay algo ahí como también como
un subtexto de dejémonos así y apartados
con sus costumbres no de no integración
verdad también sí como si nos diera
miedo que si los integramos los desarma
los deshacemos bueno no cada uno se
integra con lo que trae conserva lo que
puede yo podría decir bueno no yo cómo
voy a integrarme si mi bisabuela
toledana
jamás habría entendido que se yo que yo
esté
no esté casado con una mujer sin estar
casado es espantoso para nuestras
tradiciones y costumbres y sin embargo
qué bien que lo hacemos entonces porque
tenemos que insisto pedir que ciertos
sectores sigan aislados sigan
manteniendo esas tradiciones sobre todo
en un continente como américa que está
hecho de mezcla y eso es lo mejor que
tiene somos mezcla todos somos mezcla y
eso yo creo los hace particularmente
interesantes somos mezcla y somos muchos
movimientos también en y américa verdad
la gente se mueve te voy a citar vivimos
en un continente que use de sí mismo
decirse en un fragmento del libro esta
idea de ir nos atraviesa a todas las
clases sociales en américa latina es una
idea que está en el horizonte de
posibilidades de la vida de todos por
supuesto por distintos motivos no por
ejemplo personas en centroamérica están
buscando otra calidad de vida pero hay
otros que se van por muchísimos motivos
muy diferentes de qué habla esto además
de por supuesto como te decía no en
algunos sectores de una necesidad
bueno esto es un fenómeno relativamente
reciente en nuestra región porque
nuestra región se constituyó por
corrientes de inmigrantes desde la
primera hace 20.000 años cuando
empezaron a caminar desde asia central y
cruzaron por el estrecho de d-link y
después se desparramaron por un
continente que hasta entonces estaba
vacío hasta las dos o tres siguientes
los españoles que llegaron en 1500 y
conquistaron hicieron desastres los
africanos que esos mismos españoles
trajeron para usar como esclavos con
mucha violencia la gente del sur de
europa digamos como vos y como yo oscuro
antepasado llegaron a fin del siglo 19 o
principios del 20
todas eran olas que iban llegando
llegando llegando y en cambio en los
últimos 30 o 40 años se cambió se
invirtió la corriente y ahora en américa
es la región del mundo que más migrantes
expulsa en proporción por la cantidad de
habitantes y eso es fuerte porque es un
dato de fracaso
y sociedades que no puedan retener a sus
integrantes son sociedades que están en
momentos difíciles como que no pudimos
construir un espacio en el cual
quedarnos no pudimos construirlo y
quien emigra está diciendo yo ya pierdo
la esperanza de construir colectivamente
con los niños me voy a buscar la vida yo
solo a otro lugar porque siento que en
sociedad no lo podemos hacer y además es
una pérdida muy dolorosa y muy onerosa
en el sentido de que en general los que
se van son la gente con más energía con
más ganas de hacer algo entonces
nuestras sociedades están perdiendo esas
personas que son las que podrían cambiar
las mejorarlos otra cosa que atraviesan
y américa es sin lugar a dudas la
desigualdad bien los describirse en el
libro martín es imposible de eliminar de
hecho hay una frase que me quedo de tu
libro que es ni américa es this waltz'
es igual porque puede
si yo me preguntaba cuando está como
aceptado que américa latina es la región
más desigual del mundo y empecé cuando
me puse a trabajar con esto tratar de
entender por qué y llegué en algún
momento a esa conclusión que parece boba
porque puede
y para explicar la muy brevemente te
diría que el tema es que en toda américa
desde hace 500 años los ricos se
mantuvieron y acrecentado su riqueza en
general de la misma manera extrayendo y
exportando materia prima desde
las minas de plata de potosí en el siglo
16 hasta no sé la coca o la soja o el
petróleo o lo que sea que ahora se
extraiga se exporte es así fue siempre
la actividad principal que creó riqueza
para algunos en nuestro continente
entonces
cuando esa es la actividad central por
un lado no se necesita mucha mano de
obra y cada vez menos porque eso se está
tecnificando mucho entonces los más
ricos no necesitan que los pobres
trabajen para ellos porque con unos
pocos les alcanza y por otro lado como
esa materia prima que se extrae se
exporta los esos ricos tampoco necesitan
que haya un mercado interno porque su
mercado está afuera entonces los ricos
por decirlo de una forma muy genérica no
necesitan que los pobres ni trabajen ni
consuman este para seguir manteniendo su
ritmo de vida y sus y su riqueza con lo
cual les sobran los ricos pobres a los
ricos y lo único que necesitan es que no
se les demanden digamos para lo cual los
que yo llamo a los estados contenedores
actos en fin se dedican a contener a los
más pobres con básicamente dos
mecanismos por un lado
subsidios limosnas lanas existencias
diversas planes todo eso y por otro lado
cuando eso falla con el palo con la
represión por eso digo que porque puede
si hubiera por ejemplo si si si la
economía americana funcionara más en
términos de producción de bienes de
mercado interno y todo eso bueno los
ricos necesitarían que sus pobres
pudieran trabajar y consumir como lo
necesitan los pueden tirar aire estados
contenedor es muy interesante ese
concepto también martín ahora también
hay algo que plantea si es que los
latinoamericanos los ni americanos mejor
dicho no para seguir en la línea del
libro muchas veces pensamos que somos un
fracaso esto es algo que se palpa
muchísimo no se siente está en el aire
pensamos que somos un fracaso que no
somos lo que deberíamos ser como que
estamos quizás desperdiciando muchísimas
vidas quizás oportunidades porque cuál
dónde está la raíz por qué ocurre eso
así se viera porque no sé yo creo que
hay países y países para eso nuestro
confesémoslo el tuyo y el mío está
particularmente tocado el argentina con
los que no lo anotaron por los acentos
los pocos no los han notado porque
disimula vamos muy mal pero argentinas
particularmente tocado por esta idea
porque durante mucho tiempo desde 2008
80 hasta hace 30 o 40 años se pensó a sí
mismo como el país del futuro un país
que iba a ser extraordinario y que
trabajaba para eso digo todos migrantes
que fueron llegando y demás trabajaban
para que como decía la frase clásica su
hijo fuera fuera doctor de laboratorio
entonces encontrarse con que esos
futuros no se realizan es duro y esto
que en la argentina pasa de una manera
muy extrema yo creo que sucede en buena
parte de los otros países no americanos
martín caparrós se pasó volando el
tiempo seguiría horas diario dando
contigo debo agradecer muchísimo su
presencia en la entrevista de france mit
y cuadros y un placer esta charla al
contrario son todo muchos rollos por
favor nuevamente gracias a vos a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y también en france
24 punto com sigan con nosotros y
gracias por acompañarnos
bien